we are back now at 7 30 here on CBS
mornings with a CBS News investigation
into a child care crisis in the armed
services a crisis that could affect the
military's Readiness to fight according
to our reporting 11 000 children whose
parents are in uniform as we speak or
work in the Department of Defense are in
need of child care spots urgently right
now in some cases their parents actually
have been forced to quit the service
entirely and among those affected are
members of the Army's Elite Green Berets
including those who live and train in
the State of Florida for them their
designated Child Care site can take
hours of commuting each way every single
day senior investigative correspondent
Catherine Harris joins us now from the
Pentagon with more on this Catherine
it's a common problem for parents it's a
big issue when you're talking about our
Armed Forces good morning Good morning
Tony we've been investigating the child
care issue since June and found the
Army's seven Special Forces Group takes
on some of the most challenging missions
overseas but from more than a decade
these families say they have faced a
major challenge close to home
the number one issue when I talk to
service members and their family is
child care Colonel Kevin Trujillo leads
the Army's seven Special Forces Group
the elite Green Berets take on missions
across the globe
but at home in Florida 60 percent of the
colonel soldiers live in Crestview where
real estate and rents are cheaper they
train at Campbell Simons 20 miles to the
South unlike most army bases which have
child care on site the seventh group's
designated Child Development Center is
another 20 miles away within the
sprawling Eglin Air Force Base it's just
not a viable option to drive over an
hour a day for child care and then to
repeat that process going home Chelsea
who asked us not to use her last name
for security reasons showed us around
Crestview both in Special Forces at the
time Chelsea and her husband jungled up
to three hours of commuting each day for
child care wasted time minutes in the
day that you could be spent actually
living life with heavy traffic on Route
85 and bottlenecks at the base Gates
Chelsea was always running late you feel
like
am I failing my guys at that point I was
a squad leader am I causing them
hardship while trying to take care of my
family as well because they're both your
family they're just different families
and go play Molly Tobin faced other
child care challenges with her daughter
Olivia as a civilian married to a
special forces Commander when we moved
here in May of last year she was on 17
wait lists when we moved into our house
17 weightless 17 wait lists I received
an email saying we have an alternative
care option for you and it's an hour and
10 minutes from my house now as a family
Advocate Tobin shares the community's
concerns with base commanders how many
chelsees are out there
there's countless Chelsea's out there
according to defense department data
more than 11 000 children are waiting
for military provided Child Care the
seven Special Forces Group told CBS News
it has approximately 400. we see that
children that don't have access to
Quality child care and educational
opportunities they have a lifetime of
difficulties to include depression
anxiety learning disabilities attachment
issues Captain Tracy begin is the unit's
clinical psychologist I've seen this
probably 20 to 30 percent of my patients
have had spouses that have gone back
home specifically because of child care
issues and difficulty with finances
related to not being able to work and
have that second income the Air Force
provides for the seventh group's child
care because Campbell Simons is within
eglin's boundaries according to the Air
Force it has not built a facility on the
army base for safety reasons because it
falls within a testing range but
internal military ref records reviewed
by CBS News suggests the Air Force has
already made changes to remove all risk
from the area how can it be a safety
issue when you've got you know a shop at
a gas station you got a Subway right
here and and a church those are the
tough questions that uh family members
ask me what's the impact on the mission
when you've got someone downrange
and they're getting these concerning
phone calls from family members about
something as basic as child care yeah so
their mind is not focused on the mission
and they're not operating at an optimal
level if they're worried about concerns
whether it's family or or finances Good
job in 2015 Chelsea hit her breaking
point and left Special Forces to care
for their two sons was it hard to step
away from your military career
very
I miss it
um
a lot the group motto is the family
business they have La Familia on
everything and
yet the family is being left behind
there's a disconnect in what we're
putting out and portraying and what's
happening in as far as child care is
concerned
late last night in a statement to CBS
News the Air Force and army secretaries
confirmed they have been working
together over the summer to identify
short-term options and a long-term fix
they have agreed on a final location for
a new Child Development Center the
families told us it should be on their
base like the other services specifics
on location and how long it will take
are expected later this month Eureka
a lot of families left behind and a lot
of women forced to make sacrifices the
military can figure this out they can
build a bridge in six hours and airstrip
in twelve I mean the child care center
up there the resources it sounds like
they're working on it you would think
powerful piece thank you so much
Catherine